happy Tuesday reject nation today we are
going to watch fantastic beast - trailer
what is this movie called the crimes of
the world Greg the crime Grindelwald
before we get into this I wanted to say
thank you to everyone who's been
following us over at patreon we've been
posting so much over there I love it all
the messages and interaction we've been
having weekly we do full-length video
responses to Q&A is meaning we take a
question and we just do a full video
response to it and we're doing folding
TV show reactions over there
I personally am covering attack on Titan
right now I'm gonna post another one
today also catching up on the flash as
well John he covers Riverdale he's also
started covering Marvel's runaways right
together we've been covering my hero
academia we just started Jessica Jones
season 2 and then if time to do other
things like the Cloverfield paradox
sometimes he does Rick and Morty's and
doesn't do arrow so I want to say thank
you to everyone that's been following us
over at patreon would love to have you
guys join us as well you know speaking
of patreon outpatient the day shout out
for James stake ins because you were the
first one to tell me about this trailer
Jimbo Stokes I do have a Harry Potter
what here Harry Potter I should have
grabbed my wand he's not in this movie
he's barely a twinkle in anyone's eyes
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
something familiar I have some questions
for you professor dumbledore this is a
surprise there's a rumor that Newt
Scamander is headed to Palace
[Music]
we don't have to say for yourself
Dumbledore ever had the pleasure to
teach him you'd know new is not a great
follower of orders in times county
leaved
when you wouldn't have to pick a side
[Music]
fades back go solar no way guys away
jeez
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
to be you
[Music]
[Music]
doesn't really great teaser trailer was
a great that it look really intense this
didn't remind me that I didn't really
enjoy the first fantastic piece and I
and I kind of forgot about this movie
and I think it's cool that the first one
was an introduction into this new world
and technically a prequel in its own way
and then this one homes in more on the
prequel territory with having Dumbledore
here I think that's a nice flavor
because the first one is not
capitalizing on like this guy when he's
younger this person when they're younger
so now that we've already have like our
characters established like Newt
Scamander and his team the last one
ended with teasing Johnny Depp is
Grindelwald here you get a lot of
Dumbledore in this trailer a younger
version which you loft it looks like a
really charming charismatic version of
that looks like I feel like Jude Law can
kid more than nail bad yes I can imagine
appropriate choice so this one's giving
me that excitement of like ooh prequel
excitement now this like looks really
intense it looks really imaginative it
takes all the stuff I remember liking
about the first movie and kind of
amplifies it and at first I was a little
bit but even that like I was excited to
see the exact so again it's like now
we're getting a prequel stuff cuz the
first one felt more like it's in the
same world and then this feels a much
more connected now and I think at the
end of the day a lot of us did want a
little more of that Dumbledore we got
Hogwarts in here Johnny Depp is
Grindelwald know there's been a lot of
controversy surrounding the guy on that
we got like brief imagery of him here I
like the look he has here much better
than the look he had the full end of the
first one that the hangman guy from
Hellboy yeah he's got a little bit more
of Johnny Depp aesthetic to him yeah
just off the little bits of imagery here
I'm really intrigued to see what he'll
do with the roll I doubt this will be
something where he's phoning it in I
really really hope that that's the case
I have like a really warm place in my
heart for the Harry Potter books Harry
Potter movies especially because they
did a great job of bringing them to
life and usually they get really great
actors to fill these characters and so I
really do hope that Johnny Depp shows up
for this because that could be really
awesome his chops in this world I think
is real yeah she's perfect very potter
villain and you pointed out I I'm just
so happy the Dan Fogler is back yeah I
don't know how that's gonna work like
open up a bakery just live his life well
they they show at the end of the first
one bad like what he's creating baked
goods they were inspired by animals yeah
yeah so maybe there's some way that I
don't know Newt Scamander was able to
bring it out of him the magic of memory
we know this is like JK Rowling's riding
here and and as much as the teaser
trailer is setting it up as like it's
about mutant going up against
Grindelwald I'm sure there's gonna be
much more exploration and much more to
the plot than just like new versus
kernel you know I think that's the one
thing I am curious to see how the movie
is going to explain why it's like
Dumbledore wants you the strange animal
guy to take on this really evil wizard
yeah
oh we're not gonna get to cover that
apparently they were like in love and
had a fling even though they both a
their roles like they're yeah which I
don't know how to feel about that whole
controversy because I was like out of
the point of this movie to be like let's
halt in like no [ __ ] romance but at
the same time ya know if they're gonna
like hide in or sources that like two or
three more of these movies oh yeah
thanks for telling us that this trailer
was out patron today shout out for James
stake ins I know right now times have
not been the greatest don't worry I
won't go into detail because it's your
personal life although I really want to
share because I feel like it would make
a much more interesting video just want
to let you know that anytime you need to
talk we're here for you buddy we try I
try to get back to you as quick as
possible whenever you send us a message
or whatever I know that you are such a
dedicated loyal follower of this channel
you've become a great friend to us every
time we talk with you in the Google
Hangouts um we're always delighted to
see you we like making you laugh so even
though right now
no you're kind of in a bit of a darker
period you still bring light into our
lives whenever we get to talk with you
and ever we see you on the Google
Hangouts just know that even though you
might be a little bit down you still
lift us up every single time buddy that
does count for something I've heard a
phrase once that whenever you're going
through hell just keep going cuz you'll
eventually get out no matter what
happens in the end you'll come out a
bigger man level up really you'll be
like five inches tall spoking indoors
will be so much more funnier than you
can do it right next to the detector I
just came to make this shout out weird
well you guys can't not subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and also make sure to
check us out on patreon full-length Q&A
is TV show reactions and actually a lot
more goodies that we offer over there
too so go check us out haha